the Chinese government is blasting
pro-democracy protesters who shut down
Hong Kong's Airport and fought with riot
police some demonstrators on the other
hand are now apologizing to travelers
for the violence that grounded hundreds
of flights during the past two days our
Debora patta is in Hong Kong and has
been at that Airport Deborah big
question areas how is Beijing going to
respond to these protests
well good morning things have returned
to normal here at the airport but
Beijing is weighed in on the chaos we
saw last night calling the protests an
act of terrorism and in these newly
released satellite photos we see Chinese
military vehicles being moved into a
sports stadium apparently along the
Chinese border armed with pepper spray
and swinging battles riot police stormed
Hong Kong's International Airport last
night initially trying to help first
responders reach two injured men to find
protesters gave chase they seized an
officer's baton and turned it on him
only retreating when he stumbled back
and pulled out a gun
accused of being Chinese spies these men
felt the full brunt of protesters rage
in two separate incidents they were
kicked beaten punched and drenched in
water
protesters convinced they were
undercover officers from mainland China
attempting to pass off as one of them
this man was bound with cable ties and
left on the ground in a fetal position
finally emergency workers were allowed
to take them away Hong Kong lawmaker
Fernando Cheung rushed to the airport to
assist arriving as the violence erupted
we're in a situation that people are
getting ready
and many young people are ready to
sacrifice themselves
we don't want to see that happen for two
consecutive days protesters paralyzed
April topper ations hundreds of flights
were canceled travelers are fed up this
morning protesters held signs at the
airport apologizing for their actions
but a collision course has now been set
with both police and protesters more
quick to use force
now China can only intervene in Hong
Kong's affairs if they request military
assistance and most Hong Kong is here
think that that would be a step too far
for China and that a Tiananmen Square
style crackdown is unlikely Gail Jarvik
pada in Hong Kong thank you those
pictures still very tough to watch
imagine landing in Hong Kong getting off
of a plane to that